-Our next guest
is a sportscaster
and television personality
whose podcast "Up & Adams"
airs weekday mornings at 11:00
on FanDuel TV.
Please welcome to the show
Kay Adams, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome to the show, Kay.
How are you?
-I feel like I'm dreaming, Seth.
-Oh, my goodness.
Well, this -- We are dreaming,
because you were on your way
to Las Vegas
to start doing
your Super Bowl shows.
-Terminal one, LAX.
-Terminal one.
So you were on your way.
You were in the airport
when we reached out and asked
if you would come to our show.
-I'm on the escalator.
I look down, and my amazing
publicists were like,
"Do you want to do Seth Meyers?"
And I was like,
"Uh, let me turn around."
I went up, I turn,
I go to terminal five,
and ipso facto,
yada, yada, yada, here I am.
-Well, we're so happy
to have you.
And I should note,
I've watched your show,
and I feel like you seem to be
a person who's very good
at juggling
a lot of balls at once.
And even today, when I went
back to say hello to you
in your dressing room,
you were on a Zoom
with Trevor Lawrence.
So you were interviewing...
-Yes.
-...the Jaguars quarterback
when I came to talk
about interviewing you.
Very impressive.
-Well, it's Super Bowl week.
So, you know, the people
who cover sports and football,
it's our Super Bowl, too.
So there's Radio Row
and there's all this.
So I have this insane set.
Everything's built.
And then all these guys
are showing up.
But I'm not there
because I'm here today,
which I'm happy about.
But, yes, I had an interview
with Trevor Lawrence.
You were kind enough
to say hello.
And maybe I'll talk
to Kenny Pickett,
your Steelers quarterback.
-Thank you very much.
It'd be nice if you talked to
some Steelers for me, as well.
There's not a lot of talk
about the Steelers right now.
-We'll see if they
ever get to the Super Bowl.
-Not a lot of chatter.
So I would say
that Super Bowl week
is already mayhem
no matter where it is.
But this year
it is in Las Vegas,
which is always mayhem.
What is your expectation
for what a Super Bowl
in Las Vegas
is going to be like?
-I was at F1 a couple
of months ago.
-Okay.
-And they were so welcoming.
The city had it organized,
on lock,
but I feel like
if you're going to Vegas,
it's that, like,
Kevin McCallister
"Home Alone" moment
with the schematic.
Like, you get it on the table,
you roll it out,
and you have to plot out
where you're going
and your energy
and your coffee and whatever,
because it's going to be
absolute madness,
all the stars, and then,
of course, Usher, halftime.
Anybody excited about that?
-Now, you feel like we're not
talking enough about usher?
-I feel like -- Yeah.
-I think you're right.
-I'm a big fan of undersell,
overdeliver.
It's just a life mantra.
And I feel like we're talking
Taylor Swift, which is amazing.
And she's taking over.
And, you know, last year
was epic with Rihanna.
Then before that, we had,
you know, Doctor Dre out in L.A.
But I feel like --
and I'm going to go ahead
and say my bold take here --
this is going to be
a top-five-all-time
Super Bowl halftime show.
He's going to put on the party.
I think people forget
how many hits he has,
banger after banger, and it
will be amazing and a party.
-That's very exciting.
-Yes.
-Now, you're doing
two-hour shows
as opposed to a usual one-hour
show the whole week in Vegas.
And how many --
It seems to me
that you have a ton of guests
when you do your show.
You're just rolling in
one after the other.
Is that by design?
Do you like just
the sort of mayhem
of talking
to as many people as possible?
-Yeah, because if I don't,
then I have to talk.
-Oh, interesting.
-You like to come and, like,
you know, do your,
"Oh, this is what I think."
But then I want to get
people's stories out of them.
-Yes, absolutely.
-I think I've learned
just in covering sports,
I love the interview.
And you do an amazing job.
Like, I feel warm and comfy
and amazing here.
And I think there's
a real craft to it.
And so I really enjoy
getting stories out of people.
I mean, we have Gronk
on my show every week.
We have -- We had Will Ferrell
come on and surprise him.
Like, we have as many guests
as possible to make it a party.
-Now, Gronk -- you are doing
a live commercial with Gronk
at the Super Bowl.
-Yes.
-Now, Super Bowl commercials
are already a big deal,
but a live
Super Bowl commercial,
that has the added pressure,
I don't need to tell you,
of being live.
[ Laughter ]
-Well --
-And this is Gronk
will be trying --
Is Gronk trying to kick
a field goal again?
-He is, but I haven't really
thought about it that much.
-Oh, I'm sorry. I didn't mean
to remind you that it was live.
-Now I'm getting
a little more nervous.
No, he is.
He missed it last year.
-Yes.
-It was bedlam last year.
So now it'll be
a little more organized.
I'm going to be the reporter.
It is live during
the Super Bowl.
And then somehow
I'm going to have to be
airlifted into the stadium
so I don't miss
any of the action.
-Oh, my goodness.
-But it's live.
Like, it's happening.
He's kicking. He's practicing.
-Do you think he makes it?
-Of course I think he --
I thought he'd make it
last year.
But everybody can go to FanDuel
and guess if he makes
or misses it.
And you can get a split
of like $10 million on FanDuel.
So go and cheer Gronk on,
everybody.
-Alright, and now
what about prop bets?
Now, for those who don't know,
prop bets are the sort of bets
you wouldn't naturally think of
as far as, like,
who's going to win or over/under
or score the first touchdown.
-Right.
-What's a good prop this year?
-Is it weird that I'm obsessed
with, like, the Gatorade?
Like, I'm in the Gatorade.
-Oh, whether it gets dumped?
-No, what color
it's going to be.
-Interesting.
-That's, like, a mega --
-I can't believe you're allowed
to bet on something like that.
-It's so nerdy,
but you don't understand,
the people over at FanDuel,
the abacuses, like, you know,
the tallying everything,
they keep track
of what color the Gatorade is
for these teams all season long,
as best as they can,
to sort of make the algorithm
for what it will be.
The most popular is purple.
That was last year.
Red's a long shot,
which I'd bet on,
because I think the logos
are both red, so that's great.
Um, and, yeah,
lime yellow, whatever.
Like, just go over
and have some fun.
Prop bets are sort of
my favorite.
One interesting thing
I saw today on FanDuel,
or I heard,
was that Travis Kelce
is the most bet-on player
to win Super Bowl MVP
by like twice as much
as any of the quarterbacks,
who are, of course, favored.
-Gotcha.
-And FanDuel
thinks that's Taylor.
-Yeah, well, of course it is.
Yeah.
-No, seriously. Yeah.
-And this is a big deal.
I mean, the Taylor of it all
has been a very exciting sort of
through line to the season.
And now there's a drama because
she's going to be in Japan.
And the ambassador of Japan
basically wrote a letter
saying she's going to make it.
-Yes.
-This seems like --
I mean, the fact
that it's reached
the level of, like,
geopolitical affairs.
-It seems like a good
prop bet over at FanDuel.
Will she or will she
not make it?
I'm so happy for them.
I'm so happy for Travis,
of course.
I've covered him in my career.
-So happy.
-And, like, you know, anybody --
You know, we love love.
Don't we love love?
-We love love.
-Who doesn't love love?
-I would love to see
a little confetti angel.
-You know what I'm betting on
on FanDuel?
I'm betting on love,
'cause love always wins.
-And I'd bet on love.
-Love always wins, FanDuel.
But I'm going to bet
on it nonetheless.
-Love, Super Bowl MVPs,
and Gatorade colors.
-Now, you're from Chicago.
-Yes.
-But you're a Bengals fan.
Talk me through this.
-Um, well, I was on, um,
a national television show
covering all 32 teams,
and I sort of picked before
the big Joe Burrow season
that led them to a Super Bowl
but eventual loss --
um, I picked them
to make the playoffs
when nobody was picking them.
Is this, like, a Steelers thing?
Is this weird?
-No, I find it --
This is not a Steelers thing.
-Okay.
-And I think Joe Burrow's great
and I really like his vibe.
And I wish he didn't
play for them.
-I hear you.
-But I guess I'm wondering,
how do you -- did you have
family who was curious
as to why you were, like,
leaving the Bears
for the Bengals?
-I mean, I don't think
anybody is curious
about why you leave the Bears
to support another team.
-Now, see, now you're just
piling on the hurtfulness.
-Since 1985.
-Yes.
-Uh, basically,
I liked Joe Burrow.
He was healthy.
I felt like nobody
was picking them.
Everyone was picking every
other team in the division.
And I think when you're
a fan base that's downtrodden
and not talked about,
if you're given a little love,
sometimes when you just show a
little faith in somebody, Seth.
You've got to bet on love.
And that's what happens.
-I think we started
talking about football,
but I really hope
that the takeaway from this
is just the strength
of relationships.
-I feel like I should lay down
and do a therapy session here.
-Let's get into it.
The longer you do this,
I imagine, you must have better
relationships with the players.
They must have more confidence
that they're going to have
a good time with you.
Has that been one of the coolest
parts of your career
is just realizing
that at this point,
people know what
they're going to get
when they talk to you
and enjoy it more?
-I think I've always
approached my job
in covering football
as authentically
as a fan as possible.
It's not always easy.
You have to tackle
tough topics, of course,
but I'm very celebratory
about the game.
I get juiced.
I'm standing on my couch.
Like, I have
my favorite players.
I grew up loving Matt Forte.
I just said that to make up
for the mean Bears stuff.
I love Devin Hester.
Yeah, so I just have
a real appreciation
for what these guys do.
I mean, I took
a pickleball lesson
for the first time
this past week,
and I'm not athletic at all.
So the fact that these guys can
do what they do on this level
is so incredible
mentally and physically.
-I almost forgot to ask.
You took a pickleball lesson
for the first time.
You're going to play in a
pickleball tournament in Vegas.
I assumed because
you were playing
in a pickleball tournament,
you knew what you were doing.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
Get this. First of all,
I live in L.A. now.
I love New York.
I'm a New Yorker.
I don't want to be in L.A.,
so whenever anybody asks me,
and they ask a lot,
"Want to go play pickleball?"
I just say no, just to be
sort of a curmudgeon about it.
-Yeah. Of course.
-Yeah, very Larry David of me.
-Do you want to remind people
you're a New Yorker?
-I just -- No, I don't want to
go learn about pickleball
or what the kitchen is
or any of that nonsense, right?
So then I get asked by Smirnoff
to do this
pickleball tournament,
and they pair me
with Vernon Davis,
Super Bowl champion.
-The San Francisco 49er
tight end.
-I'm five foot tall,
like, on a good day.
Like, I got big heels on.
He's what, 7'9".
I'm going to get toppled on this
baby tennis court, first of all.
Then I'm a liability.
Then we're taking on
Scheana Shay and her husband.
So those Vanderpumpers,
like, they understand
what cameras are.
They're not going to shrink
in the light.
People are like, "Oh, but you
have an athlete next to you.
You're going to just --
You're going to beat everybody."
Do you really think, like --
You think Scheana Shay's
returning a serve
to Vernon Davis?
No, I'm going to get
exposed and pelted.
-Yeah.
-I'm going to be the scapegoat.
The whole time I'm going to be
getting worked on this court.
-Now, can I go on FanDuel
and bet against you on this?
-Yes. Safe bet.
Well said by you.
Get this, though.
Whoever loses or wins,
I think I have to
go up against --
Like, Saweetie and Lance Bass
is the other pairing, so...
-I don't know.
-I need to get
my stuff together.
-I'm starting to realize
you came to New York
not because you wanted
to be on this show.
You just wanted to get away
from that pickleball match.
-I did. You know what
I really wanted to do?
It was an easy yes,
because I just feel like
you can't be in Vegas
for more than 48 hours.
So anything to limit
my Vegas time was the move.
-And you did your show
in Zoom anyway.
You got it figured out.
But best of luck.
Have a great time out there.
And thanks so much
for being here.
You guys, that's Kay Adams,
everybody.
"Up & Adams" airs weekday
mornings at 11:00 on FanDuel TV.
We'll be right back with Nana
Kwame Adjei-Brenyah, everybody.